[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Citroën C3 on se met plus de citron
3 ans
[Musique]
j'ai envers sa table
avec un couteau
[Musique]
féroce féroce
oui bonsoir
mais nous sommes vous inviter
[Musique]
météo Roanne
d'abord
la fille derrière
tout je suis parti avec les gosses
[Musique]
et c'est une époque assez sympa c'est
des gens formidables les anciens son
tu es jeune c'est un peu difficile
moi j'ai demandé la même ma femme mais
après une bouteille de rhum blanc
j'étais allé en vacances j'étais en
vacances là-bas
ici là je commence
[Musique]
alors tu vois c'est pas grave c'est une
connaissance
Basile
[Musique]
le punch créole comme m'a appris comme
on a appris à le faire
après mon grand-père
depuis qu'on s'est retrouvé
il
a préparé à préparer
ça s'appelle le village
tu sais la Guadeloupe
et la
Martinique
française alors c'est pour ça que
il a un peu la construction un peu alors
c'est drôle
la régale en attendant
que tu trouves dans la vie il y a 2 ans
bon ils sont pas assez pris en
considération qui sont isolés et tout il
était vachement content pour toi il
était dans un dans un truc où c'était le
continent et il voulait être département
à part entière de la Guadeloupe
c'est quand tu vas quand tu vas à la
Désirade tu téléphones avant à Madame
une dame que j'appelle nounoune qui a un
restaurant tout près de l'ancienne
léproserie est une femme charmante
gentil qui fait une cuisine hallucinante
elle te dis à 7h du matin est-ce que tu
veux de la glace au coco
c'est peut-être le premier de la soirée
mais à mon avis on aura 2
et les anciens sont extraordinaires en
reçoivent chez eux d'une façon
formidable on a été la jeunesse est un
peu difficile
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui sont arrivés avec
l'idée que il avait tout à apprendre au
pays que en connaissez rien non plus
mais non je veux
je voulais rencontrer ma mère
éteindre 40 ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
Bonsoir
Gilles
[Musique]
oui
ça va comment ça va ça va bien merci
congés de la Réunion
si tu veux c'était histoire d'amener un
peu de goût de l'océan Indien un peu de
vanille
les Réunionnais vous voyez entre vous
donc on se croise parce que il y a
forcément une petite communauté mais je
pense que c'est beaucoup moins fort que
la communauté antillaise il y a une
diaspora peut-être un peu moins un peu
moins développé et puis peut-être qu'on
est un peu moins nombreux aussi je
l'ai jamais
vu
elle ressemble
pas de ce groupe malgache
[Applaudissements]
j'étais très mignon c'était les seules
stars qu'on connaissait de
une famille
absolument
quand j'ai débarqué j'avais vu avec mes
disques des grammage de léopard
et puis il y avait des trucs vachement
bien il y avait des gamins qui avaient
des groupes
et tout ça donc j'arrête j'arrive
est-ce que ta grande gueule donc on dit
quand même temps là-bas entendra quand
même
real martiniquais et créole guadeloupéen
même le créole Martinique
madame la Présidente
si tu veux la traduction pour le faire
qu'est-ce que tu m'as demandé la
même chose avec la Réunion
annonce
traduit traduction utiliser un mot qui
est très difficilement visible
ça peut être très méchant comme plutôt
affectueux
quand tu es dans une conversation en
français et que tu arrives pas à
traduire
le type
mystère
mets-moi de parler en français et de
lâcher un mot en français en créole
dedans par exemple à la Réunion pour
dire oui
ah ouais ah ouais
ils vont la réunion je ne sais pas ce
que vous faites aux réunionnaises mais
vous faites en effet bœuf
ananas et j'ai insisté une scène tu me
crois tu me crois pas deux filles en
train de se battre en boîte pour les
arsenic
c'était énorme elle se bat
non faut pas une bagarre à la Réunion
c'est pas de la bagarre c'est pas la
mienne c'est mon mec
et vous vous avez une vous avez une
substance
que qu'on peut se procurer
continue on a aux Antilles bien sûr on
appelle ça comment le
[Musique]
Guadeloupe
non chez nous on a un problème c'est
beaucoup plus grave qu'à la Réunion
c'est que nous mais ça c'est peut-être
pas le moment parce que c'est plutôt
festif on est au lendemain on est début
d'année là tu vois il y a de la cam qui
il rentre en Europe par le par les
Antilles quoi en fait
recette proximité latine
et les mecs ils n'ont pas toujours les
moyens
n'ont pas toujours les moyens mais
[Musique]
à 10h du matin
les dans les familles nobles j'avais les
nez qui récupère est
l'héritier le récupérer les terres le
nom et cetera le cadet de famille et
elle soit au service de son frère est né
soir s'engager dans les ordres soit
s'engager dans l'armée s'engager dans
les ordres rentrer dans les ordres
s'engager dans l'armée
l'île
de
la Réunion ce soir et
donc
voilà
Victor Hugo qui part sur un bateau avec
une
guillotine
il était là-bas les poursuivre il arrive
à la Guadeloupe
il arrive à la Guadeloupe Guadeloupe
reste des gens qui arrivent à s'échapper
dans la dans les dans les dans les fonds
alors qu'ils ont des noms incroyable qui
s'appelle monsieur de Polignac monsieur
de bouillon
française
arrive
arrive l'ordre de la commune
parce que en France
ces gens-là avait été certains vérité
audio il y a peut-être des jambes pas
mal là-dedans quoi donc c'était quand
même espèce de c'était comme c'était
comme une guerre civile
parce que
il fallait quand même que
je regrette
et qu'elle ne soit pas
aujourd'hui
universel que je partage avec Philippe
que je partage avec toi je partage avec
tout le monde parce que c'est le seul
homme qui a exporté l'idée de la
Révolution française
l'esclavage a été aboli et la pauvre
Joséphine qui a rencontré Napoléon
amoureux
Napoléon a rétabli l'esclavage partout
sauf la Toussaint Louverture non c'est
non il n'y aura pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas ça a été le seul qui ait
résisté à la peau Léon et
Chloé
aujourd'hui il aurait fait de la
politique il aurait été incontournable
c'est un mec qui a fait de la politique
avant même que c'était une vraie tête
c'était une vraie tête qu'il a négocié
il avait une obsession une idée
[Applaudissements]
comme ça se fait aujourd'hui
et tu sais pourquoi il a dit non parce
que tous à l'ouverture la écris premier
des Noirs au premier des blancs
mets Candy becquet becquet ça veut dire
quoi
qui a travaillé sur les langues les
langues
parlées dans les pays d'Afrique de la
corne africaine d'où était pris enlever
les esclaves pour être emmené aux
États-Unis via les Antilles météo aux
Antilles les plus forts ou les plus
malades et puis après ça se terminait
aux États-Unis en breton
j'avais dans tout dans tous les langages
du Bénin
du Sénégal
[Musique]
il
veut dire l'homme qui a le savoir
et M apostrophe becquet
BK qui veut dire l'homme qui a le
pouvoir
qui me dire
pardon de peut-être de décevoir des gens
mais les premiers des clés
c'est c'est africain qui disait alors
leur sœur machin
tu montes dans le bateau
ensuite
ils
ont débarqué
en
Guadeloupe
mais
de toute façon
pas ce qui se passe c'est que on a une
relation passionnelle la plupart des
gens qui viennent de l'extérieur et qui
arrive et qui débarque
en fait là vous êtes avec vous faites
vous fraterniser avec les colombes sur
la tête voulais détester vous les aimez
et je vous déteste vous aime je veux
dire que si Firminy là aujourd'hui si
lui il est là aujourd'hui si toi moi
c'est parce que un moment il y a que des
gens mais oui pareil il y a des gens qui
étaient sur la plantation il y a eu des
histoires de violence mais il y a des
histoires d'amour
avoir le courage de le dire parce que
les histoires d'amour
dans l'histoire
non non
non
si c'est pas trop vous demander est-ce
que je peux en placer
une.
parce qu'on peut pas être dans un pays
et prenez l'indépendance promener le
nationalisme en étant foncièrement
fonctionnaire
voilà quand on est on a cette culture
c'est une culture que nous avons
et
des fonctionnaires en Guadeloupe
par exemple quand tu chantais chanson
sexy et tout c'est pour pas chanter des
chansons plus violentes au niveau
je dis ce que je pense
tous les jours
il a tort non la raison parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille pour lui demande
de rendre des services à d'autres
mets la réunion
de la faire maintenant
dans les années 70 il y avait un fort
mouvement indépendantiste à la Réunion
il y avait possibilité de coopération
Maurice à côté c'est une île qui est
indépendante et
avec quand même beaucoup de disparité au
sein des communautés mais elle se
débrouille tout seul et à ce moment-là
la Réunion c'est quand même une plaque
tournante pour la France dans l'océan
Indien c'est quand même une l'Europe
dans l'océan Indien qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait on a assisté la Réunion on l'a
perfuser aujourd'hui la Réunion ne veux
plus être indépendant de la elle ne peux
plus ça ça rebondit et ça va dans ce
sens de ce que vous dites
possibilité de créer une opération de la
Réunion
c'est une île que j'aime consciemment
c'est chez moi c'est mon pays mais c'est
une île qui est complètement perfusé
malheureusement totalement assister
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
des boutons présente pas tout sur la
météo on ne fait pas tout de la télé ou
des chansons on doit fonctionner
réponds-moi à par contre sonner
j'aimerais savoir ce que c'est
quels sont les
gens qui ont essayé
[Applaudissements]
refuse les Antilles au Perthus la banane
au Perthus de Lacanau percussion perçu
ça et puis le jour où tu poses la
question à la majorité des gens aux
Antilles voulez-vous l'indépendance oui
ou non ils te disent oui oui oui oui
c'est formidable et puis ils font 30 km
et puis voilà ça tu sais que ça dépend
où ils font 30 km en heure ils vont en
Dominique ou c'est indépendant et la le
revenu moyen nous on part de la banane
suis navré parce que c'était le métier
de mon papa aujourd'hui
ouvrier agricole à la Martinique où est
la Guadeloupe qui coupe des bananes et
qui travaille il est payé 500 francs par
jour avec les charges sociales sécurité
sociale pour sa femme ses enfants sa
famille et cetera
la même banane que tu trouves à
Sainte-Lucie
ça change mais la même madame que tu en
Amérique centrale
dans une période quand même de
l'histoire de monde où on peut pas
continuer à perfuser à faire des trucs
comme ça à fonctionner la banane à fond
la caisse
passant d'une autre demain il faut qu'on
trouve des vraies perspectives
économiques pour ces pays là
[Applaudissements]
j'ai été déclaré à Paris dans le 92
je suis né
en grands-parents 250 ans d'arrière
grands-parents condamné à mort et d'une
d'une bonne peut-être que personne qui
s'occupe de
d'accord mais pour nous
savoir où était le révolutionnaire
aujourd'hui
appeler cette génération là
[Applaudissements]
union oui mais je peux te répondre
je suis né ici je n'ai en France je dis
parce que je suis maigre les anciens
[Applaudissements]
la vision jeudi je suis une boîte de PNL
je vais envoyer je vais en. Je suis né
en Guadeloupe mais je vis en France
mais je
vais en France il va en France
chez toi maman diamant avec ma plage mon
mon chez moi qui me connaissent depuis
mon enfant
je peux pas
complètement écolier écolier pour nous
je
[Applaudissements]
suis à la Guadeloupe où je suis né à la
France à ma différence
fais le terme
il est aussi NAIGRE que je suis
negropolitain maintenant
tu es aussi blanche qu'il aurait pu
mettre un écran.
différence entre Philippe
joue ah bah oui c'est comme ça que je
vois la chambre
indépendante
c'est pas grave et pendant faut déjà se
mettre d'accord à deux
parce que parce que Marjo avait une
raison à laquelle je voulais donner tort
je voulais comprendre pourquoi est-ce
que je pourrais être moins Nantillais
sur une terre d'accueil qui a cueilli
des
esclaves qui accueillit les gens de
toute espèce qui était condamné en
France comment est-ce que de tout genre
comment est-ce que tu peux dire qu'il y
a un antillais et qui ressemblerait ou
un noir ou un blanc plus blanc que
l'autre
c'est un français d'aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui
connaît un peu près les mêmes et puis
basta
d'accord
en génération
mettez les Indiens d'Amérique mes amis
les
alèse malienne
tu es intelligent toute la soirée j'ai
pas fait exprès excusez-moi
mais c'est vrai qui a aux Antilles à
redescendre entre les entre les
guadeloupéen déjà les Martiniquais il y
a aucune solidarité parce que tout le
monde est fière tout le monde regarde
son nombril à longueur de journée et en
fin de compte entre nous il y a beaucoup
d'amour mais il y a de la haine aussi
donc il y a il y a tout va et vient
comme ça et ça part depuis l'histoire de
l'histoire aussi parce que les esclaves
qui était dossier qui était gentille qui
tu es obéissant on les envoyer en
Martinique et ce qui était belle
c'est vrai les envoyer en Guadeloupe
c'est la base même génétiquement tout ce
qui est génétiquement déjà on est fait
pour ne pas aimer passionnément
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir c'est Sandrine et Fabienne
merci
[Musique]
mademoiselle bonsoir
votre nom
beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
que tu vas faire
fais le bruit de l'amour
je vous aime
mettre la musique des possibles
quand je suis chez moi je vous fais des
choses saines
déco l'ambiance ce soir
[Musique]
ferme ta grande gueule
biologique
[Musique]
mais sandwich au thon
je voudrais des accras des merguez et du
mouton et après qu'est-ce qui se passe
tu pues du cul
[Musique]
donner la 4G
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mets-moi
[Applaudissements]
changer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi d'en placer une autre
le tourment d'amour est un petit gâteau
aux Saintes
avec mon chéri
tu peux tomber enceinte
le petit gâteau
gâteau à base de farine et de noix de
coco
gâteau à base de musclé de spermato
n'oublie pas de demander
si tu veux
n'oublie pas de demander le gâteau au
coco
avec un zeste
Terre-de-Haut
et Terre-de-Bas
facilement au bar
velouté
tout et parfumé
[Musique]
n'oublie pas de demander le d'amour
d'amour
si tu veux tomber enceinte
gâteau au coco
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
magasin tout nu
[Musique]
continuez
tu me donnes ta passion et je trouve sa
femme
je sais pas danser
super amant
aujourd'hui tu vas l'oublier tous les
tocards qui n'ont pas assuré
dans la vie il y a le sexe aussi
pas besoin de 9
tu sais faire la planche
son pantalon
aujourd'hui de la passion
c'est quoi la passion
de la passion
quelle est la passion de
la passion
ok c'est bon
[Musique]